Willy.
Come to me, come to me in my time of need, hold me. Good morning Hank.
It's Sunday, some snowy day in December, and today. I'm going to conquer one of my greatest phobias:
Heights
Should I let Willy tell this story instead of me telling it?
Maybe so.
(Sarah): It'll be easier to cope
Ok, so John recently went to an author party with Scott Westerfeld and Justine Larbalestier
And they were teasing him about his profound fear of heights
and they pointed to a table in a hotel room and
said: "How much would it cost for you to stand on top of that table?"
So John had to come up with a monetary figure that was high enough that he wouldn't have to stand on the table
but low enough that he wouldn't seem entirely crazy for being unwilling to stand on top of the table, due to his profound fear of heights.
And the number he finally came up with:
Five thousand dollars.
To which Scott Westerfeld and Justine Larbalestier said:
"Okay" , and then offered to make a donation of five thousand - but Willy you are supposed to be telling this story,
not licking - and then offered him a donation of
$5000 to his favorite charities if he would stand on top of the table.
And then being my courageous owner,
I'm sure you can imagine what John did next.
He completely failed to get on top of the table because he is a gigantic wuss.
But Scott and Justine agreed to extend the deadline of table standing until today, so today
I am going to stand on top of a table
for the children.
I mean people are gonna think that I'm literally crazy.
Can we take my pulse for the purposes of showing that I'm legitimately afraid?
[fast breathing]
What do you think it is?
(Sarah): I don't know, it's high.
I don't think getting on the table will be hard at all. I think that standing on the table will be exceptionally hard.
So...
I guess I just...
[nervous laughter]
Yeah, yeah, I can't do it. I liter- , I don't think I can do it, man.
(Sarah): Get on the table.
[quiet giggle from Sarah]
Oh my God.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do it, and then I'm going to, and then I'm going to stand up on the table
and then I'm going to get right back down.
Okay, can we have another countdown?
I'm going to-. I'm going to stand up on the table. I'm going to get right back down. I'm gonna go right now.I'm gonna go.
I'm up.
F***.
Okay, I´m on the table.
Ha ha ha ha ha yes!! [singing] I got on the table! I stood on the table!
Yess!!!
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
Hank, I don't want to brag but I think that today I have shown a lot of, you know,
physical courage. I have proven once and for all that
nerdfighters are tough. It's like Franklin Delano Roosevelt said, we have nothing to fear but fear itself.
And heights.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Willy! Willy, let's run through the snow together!!
Oh!
This way! This way! This way!